en 1935 l'économiste daniel ellsberg
travailler pour le pentagone le quartier
général de l'armée américaine il avait
pour mission de trouver des
justificatifs un prolongement de la
guerre du vietnam déjà démarré depuis
dix ans ellsberg apprend alors que deux
conseillers américains s'étaient fait
capturé et tué par les forces
vietnamiennes un colonel de l'armée
américaine avait même pu prendre des
photos de leur corps avec les traces de
chaîne espère qu avait trouvé le capote
car même s'ils s'agissait d'un cas isolé
peut être le premier et le seul de toute
l'histoire du vietnam jusque là
l'histoire était suffisante pour
interpeller le président des états unis
et prolonger la guerre albert reçu les
louanges que ses supérieurs cependant à
ce moment là il était déjà opposé à la
guerre du vietnam mais surtout petit à
petit j'espère que ça en dit content que
beaucoup d informations qui suggérait un
contrôle du territoire par les forces
américaines étaient fabriquées de toutes
pièces la guerre était hors de contrôle
est très loin d'arriver à son terme
cependant s berck ne se sentait pas
coupable ne se sentait même pas
responsables il continua à travailler
comme il le faisait avec le soutien de
ses supérieurs pour justifier la
poursuite de la guerre
et puis au début de l'année 1968 la
fameuse offensive du tête des forces
nord-vietnamienne montra à quel point
les états unis étaient dépassés par la
guerre ellsberg se rendit alors compte
que prolonger la guerre n'allait cause
et que davantage de victimes à la fois
du côté américain et du côté vietnamien
toutefois l'élection d'un nouveau
président des états unis ne changeait
rien au contraire comme ses
prédécesseurs le président nixon
renforça la présence américaine au
vietnam et dans sa des opérations de
bombardement massif au final trois fois
plus de bons bords ont été largués dans
ce pays que pendant toute la seconde
guerre mondiale à travers le monde qui
plus est l'utilisation abusive de
l'agent orange un produit chimique
destiné à déforester les jungle
vietnamienne pour empêcher les forces
vietnamiennes de se cacher cet agent
orange aura des conséquences tragiques
sur leur fertilité des vietnamiens
exposées à ce produit et en particulier
sur la malformation de leurs embryons et
d'ailleurs je peux en témoigner
personnellement ayant un oncle qui a été
engagée dans la guerre du vietnam et
dont le fils aura été mal formés
handicapées mentalement et des cdd sa
trentaine s'en fut trop pour s berg qui
décida de révéler au grand public toute
l'atrocité de cette guerre jusque-là
classés secret défense pendant de longs
bras ellsberg récupérer discrètement des
documents de son lot de travail
photocopier des milliers de documents et
contacté des journalistes pour préparer
le plus gros hic de l'histoire de
l'armée américaine
tout en sachant pertinemment les risques
énormes qu'ils encourraient à titre
individuel en devenant ainsi l'ennemi
public numéro un du président de la plus
grande puissance mondiale en plus d'être
surveillés et harcelés sbq poursuivi en
justice est risqué cent quinze ans de
prison en 1971 le new york times suivi
d'autres journaux publiaient enfin la
révélation stupéfiante desberg les
pentagon papers malgré des pressions et
des menaces de poursuites judiciaires
que les journalistes de ses rédactions
ont alors reçu des autorités américaines
mais la vérité finit par éclater non les
états unis n'avaient pas le contrôle du
vietnam et oui ils violaient au
quotidien la convention de genève en
bombardant des civils et on torturant
des prisonniers de guerre des vagues de
protestation contre la guerre envahir
alors les villes américaines ellsberg
avait triomphé ou du moins c'est
l'impression qu'on pouvait avoir pendant
les semaines qui suivirent la
publication des pentagon papers
mais comme les bergs explique lui-même
pour gagner la guerre de l'information
il ne suffit pas de révéler des
informations importantes
je
respecte mes fils et câbles
d'acier marc thibault
nous des choses
[Musique]
panorama
ces gens
en fait la guerre de l'information dans
laquelle elle berg s'était engagé
n'avait fait que commencer et ce n'est
qu'en 1974 qui la remportera suite à
l'affairé watergate qui conduisit à la
démission de nixon même s'il faudra
attendre encore neuf mois pour que les
états unis capitule enfin et met fin au
massacre de 2 millions de vietnamiens
ce qu'on montre surtout l'histoire des
perth sait à quel point la guerre de
l'information est critique pour la
survenue le maintien et l'issue des
guerres physiques en particulier l'appel
à la haine envers une autre population
est un outil dont beaucoup de
gouvernements abusent aussi souvent pour
obtenir l'adhésion du peuple qui
gouvernent et ainsi accéder au pouvoir
mais de façon terrifiante ceci amplifie
aussi gravement le risque de violence
désastreuse on en a déjà parlé dans le
cas du myanmar et de l'ethiopie et on
pourrait parler de l' influence très
dangereuse d'un certain murdoch sur les
médias anglophones j'aurais pu également
mentionné ce qui se passe actuellement
en france mais vu l'actualité je vous
propose d'étudier le cas des autorités
russes car il est de surcroît
particulièrement édifiant en effet les
médias russes ont tenté de dépeindre les
ukrainiens comme des rebelles à la solde
de l'otan et des états unis voulant
anéantir les communauté russophone pire
encore certaines des informations vont
jusqu'à prétendre que le nazisme a
triomphé en ukraine et que la russie
étant seul à justifier a attaqué les
forces du craignent haine dans le but
d'avoir l'adhésion du peuple russe voir
celui des peuples étrangers mais comme
on l'a vu avec les pentagone papers
révélé l'information n'est que la
première étape de la guerre de
l'information pour que l'information est
un impact majeur il est critique de la
diffuser massivement pour y arriver les
forces que désinformation russe repose
sur des médias étatiques capable de
monopoliser l'attention d'une grande
partie de la population russe en
particulier les populations plus âgées
mais par ailleurs ils peuvent exploiter
un travail qu'ils ont initiée depuis de
longues années en établissant des
réseaux de trolls et de compter un
succès comme la chaîne youtube russia
today selon guillaume chazot ancien
employé de google cette chaîne a été
recommandée 100 milliards de fois par
l'algorithme de youtube 100 milliards de
fois et on y trouve des vidéos aussi
trompeuse que des armes et l'ukraine la
russie ne pouvait pas ne pas agir encore
les anonymous déclare la cyberguerre au
gouvernement russe donnant ainsi
l'impression que le gouvernement russe
est une victime qui cherchent avant tout
la paix en particulier bien des
objectifs de désinformation russe c'est
certainement la radicalisation du
mouvement séparatiste pro russe en
ukraine qui depuis 2014 semble alimenter
financièrement et en armement pour semer
le trouble et le chaos notamment dans le
donbass et surtout pour maintenir une
critique permanente des autorités
ukrainiennes
le rôle central des algorithmes de
recommandations de cette guerre mondiale
de l'information semble de mieux en
mieux compris par les gouvernements que
ce soit du côté américain ou un sénateur
aux proches aux réseaux sociaux de
diffuser massivement des fossés
informations diffusées par les agences
russes ou du côté russe qui restreint
désormais l'accès à facebook et à
twitter depuis l'intérieur de la russie
après avoir poursuivi facebook en
justice deux mois avant l'invasion en
fait facebook kobe déjà depuis des
années à des exigences des autorités
russes et plus exactement roskomnadzor
le service fédéral pour la supervision
des communications des technologies de
l'information et des médias de masse les
propagandes russes semblent par ailleurs
abondamment et efficacement diffusée sur
les autres réseaux sociaux en
particulier tik tok et télégramme ici le
pdg de télégrammes un instant songé
modéré certains flux télégramme il a
vite fait marche arrière face à ce chaos
informationnel la commission européenne
a finalement riposté et s'est attaqué
frontalement à l'info garde des
autorités russes en panne hissant les
dangereux médias étatiques spoutnik et
russia today de l'union européenne les
autorités russes ont aussi bien connus
pour leur armée de trolls vous sied
appelé ferme de trolls qui vont créer
toutes sortes d'activités fabriqué pour
induire les algorithmes de
recommandation en erreur m en tendance
des sujets favorable à l'or narratif est
noyé toutes les informations qui les
dérangent pétrole peuvent alors ensuite
massivement signaler des contenus qu'ils
veulent réduire au silence comme les
services open source et d'intelligence
que twitter a malencontreusement bloqués
peu de temps avant l'invasion russe ces
fermes de troll cherche aussi
constamment à diviser l'opinion publique
des démocraties pour les affaiblir
politiquement par exemple en contenant à
la chaîne des contenus polarisant mais
potentiellement parfaitement factuelle
ou en finançant la production de la
mésinformation comme cela a été révélé
notamment par darty biology avec
l'objectif que l'interlocuteur des
autorités russes se sentent lui-même
menacé par l'opinion publique de son
propre pays enfin les fermes de troll
exploite aussi beaucoup le harcèlement
ou la menace pour décourager les
critiques à l'instar du président russe
en personne ou abusent de commentaire de
la forme je préférais quand tu parlais
de maths pour détourner l'attention des
créateurs de contenu et décourager à
parler de sujets sensibles
selon le prix nobel de la paix dimitri
mouratov l'opinion publique russe est la
clé pour mettre fin non seulement au
conflit mais plus généralement velléités
des autorités russes malheureusement
toute protestation russe est illégale et
les protestants risque au moins la
prison pour exprimer leur désaccord avec
les décisions de leur gouvernement ceci
n'a toutefois pas freiner des milliers
de russes qui au péril de leur vie n'ont
pas hésité à défiler massivement en
russie pour appeler à la paix comme
daniel ellsberg ces femmes et ces hommes
sont de véritables héros prêt à se
sacrifier pour protéger des victimes
innocentes très loin de chez eux
je me sens incroyablement admiratif
reconnaissant et inspiré par la
bienveillance extraordinaire et par leur
courage incroyable
selon l'organisation non gouvernementale
human rights watch ce serait plus de
3000 protestants anti hier que les
forces de police russes auraient été
arrêtés souvent en abusant de violence
et parfois en se mettant à plusieurs
pour contrôler un unique manifestants
pacifistes des milliers d'autres russes
sont mobilisés en ligne en signant des
pétitions pour montrer que des corps de
métier tout entier s'opposent au
gouvernement russe en particulier des
chercheurs des ingénieurs et des
enseignants selon ces chiffres il y
aurait même une pétition qui aura
récolté plus de 780 mille signatures
même si on va mettre un gros bémol à
cela parce qu'il ya certainement
beaucoup de faux comptes et peut-être
même beaucoup de faux compte parmi les
signataires je suis plus
particulièrement admiratif encore des
influenceurs qui en prenant publiquement
position pour la paix se mettent
clairement beaucoup plus à risque encore
comme le rappeur oxymoron ou comme les
joueurs de tennis andrei roublev et
danila medvedev
quel héros mais les plus courageux et
les plus héroïques dans cette affaire ce
sont sans doute les 100 députés
municipaux russes venant de différentes
villes à travers le pays qui ont pris
position publiquement contre la guerre
en signant de leur propre nom un
document affirmant entre autres que je
cite les espoirs d'une bonne vie en
russie s'effondre sous nos yeux oui car
malheureusement les sanctions ont frappé
le peuple pas les oligarques russes je
ne peux pas suffisamment souligné le
risque que ses pairs prennent si poutine
n'est pas déchu suite à la guerre en
ukraine ces héros de la nation russe
risque non seulement la prison mais
aussi et surtout la torture comme l'ont
subi d'autres opposants avant eux ces
gens sont de véritables héros quoi qu'il
en soit comme le prix nobel de la paix
dimitri mouratov le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky semble penser lui
aussi que l'opinion publique russe est
la clef de l'enjeu ukrainien peu de
temps après les premiers bombardements
c'est en effet au peuple russe que le
président zelensky a choisi de
s'adresser
ron nagle
quatre élus du congrès
tandis qu'à l'ouest green card bosnie
pour thalys ou bi dick van brakel ya
zina je dois être membre à chiny paca je
pars réussissent comme des vignes
n'engage dernier récit d'un niveau vide
et annie d'origine et ville est pauvre
après deux tours jetons mongenan astana
800 pas qu'on me pose est est-ce que
rocco broustra par sinik rouge a dit mir
se dit ça ça se trouve ce n'est pas moi
venons en au ciel strauss kahn
a dit le russe qui va aisni ya trop de
crédit aux batteries tellement cette
approche non à des visites tout le cas à
3 gr jeunes à risque et pirate jack ou
sauvages
je souhaite de tout coeur que via
télégramme ou d'autres réseaux sociaux
son message sera délivré un maximum de
russes et pour cela il va falloir
réussir à contourner les services de
désinformation des autorités russes
jusque-là actualité oblige je me suis
beaucoup arrêté sur le cas de la russie
cependant il faut bien se rendre compte
que la guerre mondiale de l'information
a déjà a très largement commencé à
travers le monde notamment sur internet
une façon très préoccupante celle ci
fait intervenir des acteurs très
dangereux venant des quatre coins du
monde y compris aux portes de l'europe
de nombreux dirigeants parfois qualifiés
de dictateurs exploiter des outils de
désinformation sophistiqués pour
affaiblir ou manipuler les démocraties
d'erdogan en turquie à loukachenko en
biélorussie en passant par mois métis au
maroc où il a mal hier en azerbaïdjan
pour ne nommer qu'eux parmi tant
d'autres ces dirigeants abusent de ferme
de troll pour protéger leur pouvoir par
exemple en harcelant les mouvements de
droits de l'homme dans leur pays et leur
diaspora en produisant parfois même des
10 films pornographiques pour
déstabiliser les journalistes ou en
fabriquant des scandales de toutes
pièces en éliminant l'opposition
journalistique ces pays se prémunissent
de whistleblowers comme daniel ellsberg
et peuvent plus facilement contrôlé le
régime informationnel de leur peuple à
l'instar de la russie actuellement ces
états autoritaires ont désormais de
puissants outils de désinformation en
ligne comme la chaîne chauve tv
contrôlée par le gouvernement marocain
qui a été mentionnée par timminco buhari
clr l'une des plus importantes
conférences mondiales en intelligence
artificielle et oui je pars de la même
teelgo beau que google avait viré moins
d'un mois après le début de la guerre en
ethiopie alors même qu'elle lançait un
projet sur les appels à génocide qui ont
lieu dans la région en plus de la
propagande de nombreux et à exploiter
des armes de surveillance redoutablement
efficaces comme le logiciel espion
pegasus capable d'infiltrer un téléphone
sans que la victime ne cliquent sur
aucun bouton à l'instar encore une fois
de daniel ellsberg de nombreux
journalistes ont ainsi été attaqués par
des gouvernements autoritaires mais ce
n'est pas tout selon amnesty
international comme le super
milliardaire greffe pesos le président
de la république française emmanuel
macron aurait lui aussi été victime
d'une attaque medias us commandité par
le gouvernement marocain étrangement
toutefois le gouvernement français n'a
pas réagi à cette attaque supposer ce
qui pourrait signifier qu'il doute de
l'attak ou peut être plus probablement
encore qu'ils en ont été effectivement
victime mais ne veulent pas fâché le
gouvernement marocain car celui ci
aurait ainsi accès à des données très
sensibles
2 très préoccupante des forces des
étrangères d'infos guerre semble avoir
ainsi réussi à infiltrer et à corrompre
les démocraties comme le révèle le
documentaire la caviar connexion de la
chaîne arte en particulier deux
parlementaires européens l'italien luca
volonté et l'allemand uwe douars de link
nerfs ont été condamnés pour corruption
de façon troublante peut-être à cause de
ce lobbying les gouvernements
démocratiques se sont engagés dans du
trafic d'armes avec des gouvernements
étrangers pourtant bien connus pour
leurs activités d'un fauve guerre par
exemple la france a récemment vendu 80
rafale des avions de combat aux émirats
arabes unis alors même que le
gouvernement de ce pays est connu pour
son pegasus locale appelée dark matters
et qu'ils mènent des opérations de
drones autonome en ethiopie d'ailleurs
le budget militaire des émirats arabes
unis dont l'économie repose en partie
sur une forme d' esclavage moderne ce
budget militaire est supérieur à celui
de l'espagne est elle à moitié de celui
de la france pour une population huit
fois moins nombreuses de façon très
préoccupante bonne partie de ces
investissements massifs permet
probablement le développement de drones
autonome de guerre y compris dans des
pays aux régimes et aux institutions
moins fiables comme l'azerbaïdjan et le
maroc qui semble avoir tous deux fait
usage que ces nouvelles armes de guerre
peut-être plus surprenant encore la
turquie dispose non seulement de drones
elle en exporte même désormais de façon
terrifiante dans les années à venir ces
nouvelles armes de guerre dévastatrice
pourrait se démocratiser et être ainsi à
la portée de milliers voire de millions
d'organisations différentes
le marché de ces armes pourraient
bientôt être complètement hors de
contrôle de toute autorité et des
attaques dévastatrices pourrait alors
survenir n'importe où nous nous
dirigeons peut-être vers un futur où un
grand nombre d'individus différents
venant des quatre coins du monde pour
tous déclencher un cataclysme
monumentale en écrivant une poignée de
commandes seulement sur un ordinateur
la guerre mondiale de l'info on n'a rien
de nouveau depuis les débuts de la
guerre les dirigeants du mobiliser leur
peuple pour prendre les armes à l'aide
de mots ou d'image en cela une nouvelle
technologie n'ont fait que déplacer le
problème les champs de bataille au
prospectus des prospectus à la radio le
radio à la télévision et de la
télévision à internet l'info guerre là
rien de nouveau là toujours été critique
pour initier ou arrêter des guerres et
l'opinion publique a souvent été le
principal frein aux élans expansionniste
de certains dictateurs comme par le
passé il nous faut donc y occuper le
terrain pour déconstruire les narratif
trompeur révéler les atrocités de cayres
et appelé à une paix si rare dans
l'histoire de l'humanité en fait cela
est sans doute devenu plus urgent que
jamais en effet parce que les armes de
guerre disponibles sont de plus en plus
terrifiante l'est devenue critique de
prendre beaucoup plus soin de la qualité
de l'information diffusée à travers tous
les canaux et de ne plus se contenter du
laisser-faire désastreux du contrôle
autoritaire terrifiant de l'information
qui aura dominé le monde depuis des
millénaires la guerre de l'information
déterminera le futur de l'humanité en
particulier dans son livre fascinant
ouch angie apple le juriste et chercheur
cass sunstein souligne à quel point
cette info guerre peut conduire des
soulèvements populaires spectaculaire et
souvent inattendues y compris par les
experts notamment lorsque peu de gens ou
d'une compréhension correcte de ce que
leur père pense selon sunstein la clé de
tels soulèvements est un phénomène de
réaction en chaîne ou la popularité
d'une contestation peut soudainement
convaincre une grande fraction de la
population de prendre part à la
contestation à leur tour et enfin dire
ce qu'il pense vraiment y compris
lorsque ceux ci se fait au péril de leur
vie sachant cela dans le cadre de la
guerre en ukraine en particulier il
semble absolument critique d'encourager
les protestations russes en les
partageant massivement sur les réseaux
sociaux et en les justifiant avec des
informations de qualité en particulier
sur ce qui se passe actuellement en
ukraine souvenez vous beaucoup de russes
pensent qu'il n'y a pas eu d' invasion
russe et que l'armée russe est
simplement venu apporter son aide aux
séparatistes pro russes pour stabiliser
des régions instables en particulier
selon les derniers chiffres que j'ai pu
trouver le président russe est encore
incroyablement populaire dans l'opinion
publique russe ce qui rend sa
contestation encore très difficile
combattre la désinformation russe est
alors critique pour que cette opinion
publique jugent les autorités russes
avec la meilleure information possible
et pour cela il est nécessaire
d'identifier les contenus
informationnels de qualité et vous
pouvez aider en comparant la qualité de
différentes vidéos par exemple sur le
sujet de l'ukraine via la plateforme
tournesol dont c'est vraiment l'objectif
dans cette guerre de l'information nous
avons tous un rôle à jouer en
particulier il semble crucial que les
influenceurs mesure l'ampleur de la
charge morale qui les incombe leur
silence peut en particulier donné
l'impression que la crise en ukraine ne
mérite pas l'attention qu'elle reçoit
actuellement et ceux ci risquent de
normaliser le fait d'ignorer les
souffrances ukrainienne même quand ce
n'est pas l'objectif des influenceurs en
particulier il ne faut pas imaginer que
le président poutine est aujourd'hui
intouchable comme tout dirigeant son
pouvoir dépend de la confiance de son
entourage en sa capacité à garder le
pouvoir si à cause de l'info guerre
l'entourage de vladimir poutine perd
confiance en son président alors des
bouleversements traces tic pourraient
survenir rapidement en fait poutine est
sans doute plus menacé que jamais et il
est d'autant plus important que ensemble
nous lui infligions l'offensive d'infos
guère décisive pour le faire tomber et
mettre fin à la guerre en ukraine et
ainsi atteindre d'une des plus grandes
menaces qui pèsent aujourd'hui sur la
paix pour le monde